uh he was vicious in business I mean he
would basically go out and buy all these
small oil refineries and uh if they
didn't sell he goes hey look I'm going
to write you a fair deal
if you don't take my offer I'm gonna
trust you I'll show you all my
accounting and all my Revenue so you
know I'm gonna Crush you so I think you
should take this deal so we can get rich
together otherwise you're dead
[Music]
all right what's happening a lot of
people have been asking me about what
I've been reading lately because I've
read a lot of amazing books and I want
to do a quick pod a quick episode that
explains what I'm reading and how it
relates to business most of these books
we're only going to go through three or
four of them most of these books are not
business related but there's a lot of
learnings for business people I actually
don't read business books I haven't read
a business book in like
five years they bore me
and lately I've been reading a ton of
like Adventure stuff so things about
like
oh when Americans expanded West or about
people uh discovering uh North America
or
ship stories and Pirates I love that
type of stuff the reason I love that
type of stuff is because it basically
makes my daily life it turns the volume
down it's kind of like I like the box
and I like to like get into adventures
and things like that because it makes my
day-to-day which is mostly work and
business stuff it makes it way easier
because I'm like damn I just read the
story about Shackleton and how I
got deserted on Antarctica for two years
this business stuff is easy so I like
things like that and so here are three
or four books that I've read lately that
I've had huge impacts on my day-to-day
with business and I'm gonna Explain how
and why they did that so the first one
is called on undaunted courage it's the
story of Lewis and Clark
if you're an American if you're not
American I actually don't know what you
know about Lewis and Clark If You're an
American you've heard that term Lewis
and Clark and you know that they were
people to guys that kind of like were
sent to discover the West well this
story kind of Dives deep on it and it's
a story about in like I believe 1804 so
is this guy named Meriwether Lewis and
William Clark they were tasked by Thomas
Jefferson to start in St Louis and to
discover the the the west of the country
at this point Jefferson had just bought
a bunch of what is now the western part
of America from Napoleon and of course
Indians and Native Americans they knew
all about it but no American had
actually been really too far west of the
Mississippi and so what's interesting is
that Lewis who is the main guy Lewis was
kind of the captain of the ship he took
30 folks so him and uh William Clark
took 30 folks and they went to to
California and back
but no one had ever done that at the
time and what's amazing is that
Meriwether Lewis was only 31 years old
and I thought that that was incredibly
impressive and they took two years to do
it so imagine going off on like a
two-year hiking trip and a place you've
never been not knowing what you're gonna
find and hoping that you come back and I
found that to be uh such a good book the
first big thing that I learned is
punishment is necessary and so in
today's kind of like Tech culture I
think I used to joke about HubSpot the
company that bought mine
I was like you guys are too nice man you
guys are like way too friendly
um and I think that that's like a common
theme with like most tech companies is
they're way too friendly they're way too
nice and I can't stand that and I think
I fall victim to that as well the reason
being is
when I read this book there's just some
like a bunch of different stories so
imagine just a 31 year old Lewis
uh and only 30 guys it's easy to get
like chummy with them but he was really
really strict and so there's a story
about how they had to set up a a fork
during the winter time and they set it
up along with these Native Americans who
they got to know and they set up this
fort and they built this wall and one of
Louis's men at night time hopped over
the fence after he had just gotten done
hanging out with the Indians and an
Indian saw him and also hopped the fence
and they're like hey man you can't be
here this is just our space whatever and
the next morning Lewis heard about it
and they whipped their guy 500 times
it's called lashing so they basically
tied him to a tree and whipped them 500
times and which is like a horrible
punishment and that's like an extreme
punishment but the reason he did it was
because he's like look you just hey you
broke the rule we said you can't climb
this fence and B now they know that
they're allowed to do that too and so he
had really really strict rules but that
sounds like crazy like why would you do
something like that that bad but
basically his point was look discipline
breeds excellence and I have to have
strict rules and I have to punish people
in front of others when they've done
something wrong so everyone knows here's
the line don't cross it but also by
enforcing these strict rules it's going
to make people know that like what our
standards are and so there's another TV
show I've just started watching it's
called um
uh bear the bear it's about this guy
who's got this uh Diner in Chicago
and he basically it's kind of like a
crappy Diner and he's trying to like
step it up and so he sends his cousin to
work at this fancy restaurant that's
known for their strict discipline and
the cousin gets to the restaurant that's
really strict and he's like dude this is
I'm not following all these
rules they have all these rules about
like you can't talk to you can't talk to
your co-workers in front of the guest
you have to be you only can pay
attention to them or I don't want you
um or you have to like polish the forks
your first week of work and you got to
spend three hours polishing the forks
because the forks can't have any
watermarks on them and event eventually
at the end of the week he's like man I
love this I wish I I crave this
discipline because what this does is it
lets me know where the rules are what
the boundaries are and it gives me a
straightforward path that I can go on
and it creates this uh this this culture
of discipline and excellence and I love
that and so big takeaway from this book
is you have to have punishment in order
to create discipline I think that in our
culture right now with tech we are way
too forgiving about certain things and
it just reminded me that like firing
people and things like that I actually
think it's necessary the second thing is
finding your personal product Market fit
so Lewis was an Outdoorsman his whole
life and then he eventually had somewhat
like an office job so he worked with
Thomas Jefferson where he
like was like his uh I don't remember
what his title is but he would just be
inside the house all day with Jefferson
like helping him create new laws and how
to be diplomatic and things like that
and he has this great line in this book
he says
uh the the author says on his 31st
birthday Lewis wrote in a famous passage
the day I completed my 31st year I
reflected that I had yet has done but
little very little indeed to further the
happiness of the human race
I viewed with regret the hours that I've
spent in idolence and now sorely feel
that the want of that information which
those hours would have given me has been
judiciously expended meaning he's like
I've wasted my time I have to act and I
really appreciate that that he like said
look I've been a total waste up until
now now I'm gonna get after it and this
is my mission and so finding your
personal product Market fit we talk
about finding your product Market fit
with your company I think you have to
find your personal product Market fit
and so I found that to be incredibly
inspiring and the last thing from this
book he understood that the people that
you're leading each of them have
individual traits and you have to figure
out those traits and use that to
motivate people when I was first
starting in business I did a really bad
job of understanding that every person
is unique and I used to think that I
could just tell them what to do that's
not the case
and so in this book there's this great
line where he says Lewis had a sense a
feel for how his family was doing he
knew exactly when to take a break when
to issue issue a gill when to push for
more when to encourage when to inspire
want to tell a joke when to be tough he
knew how to keep a distance from himself
and the men and just how big it should
be
and he did a really good job of figuring
out what motivated each person and that
has taught me that I should probably do
the same before I was like you're kind
of all just a bunch of robots to me it's
just human capital instead in order to
be a great leader particularly like
Lewis you have to do a good job of
figuring out what motivates people in
creating rewards creating punishment in
order to fit each person and hopefully
making your whole crew better
the second book that I recommend it's
called the operator and it's by Robert
O'Neill and it's about the time when
SEAL Team Six was deployed to go and
kill Bin Laden and I love reading these
these like Army and military books but
there's this great line so basically
uh Robert O'Neill and his and team SEAL
Team Six they were deployed on this
helicopter and they were on their way to
Bin Laden's compound
and he said once we get on this Mission
we weren't we knew that we weren't going
to see our kids again or kiss our wives
we'll never eat another steak or smoke
another cigar and there's this like
thing about like he's going to on this
helicopter and he knows or he thinks
that he's never going to come back and
survive or see his family again and I
found that like so encouraging because
sometimes I'm afraid to tweet something
or I'm afraid to like start a business
or I'm afraid to make a phone call when
these guys are like going to like
they it's a suicide mission they think
that they're getting dropped off in Bin
Laden's compound and they're going to
kill them and but then they're gonna die
and I was like man if these guys can do
this I could do this other stuff that's
no big deal and so I find like a lot of
inspiration from Little stories like
that there's this other thing in the
book where this other story in the book
where
basically they figured out where they
thought Bin Laden was and it was like
this compound imagine like
in a house an eight-room Mansion
surrounded by a big fence and so they
did this thing where they built a a
model of this house and they spent weeks
running through the house and like
saying all right at this point you're
going to run this many steps then that's
when the room is going to open here
you're likely going to find these people
in the room but then you're going to do
this and they like did it so much that
they knew how many steps they were going
to take they knew how many seconds each
thing was going to take and they planned
like crazy but here's the thing when
they landed the helicopter into the
compound it crashed so from the second
the mission started the whole plan got
thrown out the the door and everything
got screwed up but there's this thing
called commander's intent a commander's
intent is when uh the intent of the
outcome is clear so you have to
verbalize it you have to write it down
you have to say I'm going to or the out
the desired outcome is x y and z
and the reason you plan even though you
know the plan is going to go to the
reason you plan is because a when
something does go to you have
something to fall back on and B it gives
your men or your your employees it gives
them confidence that like look it's
going to be okay uh We've we've swapped
the details but when it doesn't go okay
you know what the commander's intent is
and I think that for me with my first
business I remember starting it and I
said by the age of 30 I want to have
this much money
great that's my commander's intent the
reason I wanted this much money was I
wanted like Financial Freedom and not to
stress out
and then once I had my commander's
intent I created a plan and I created
the rules I was going to follow when I
created what input I needed to get to my
commander's intent and as expected a lot
of things changed so I said like I want
this much revenue by year two this much
revenue by year five which means I could
probably sell I missed revenue on
sometimes I uh uh exceeded Revenue other
times I had to fire people I changed my
values sometimes like things happened
along the way but because I had my own
commander's intent I said no to
everything that didn't get me to my
desired outcome and I had something to
fall back on when I was making new
decisions so I thought to myself is this
going to get me closer to that
particular goal if yes do it if no don't
do it and avoid it and so with the
operator I learned about commander's
intent and uh planning
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most crms are a cobble
together mess
often actually looks gorgeous I think I
love our new CRM our software is the
best HubSpot grow better
in the last book
I lied and said it I didn't read a lot
of business books this one's kind of
businessy it's called Titan and it's
about uh the biography of John
Rockefeller John Rockefeller was a
businessman in the late 1800s all the
way to like 1930 or so he created
Standard Oil so Standard Oil it's hard
to compare to what it is nowadays
because it was so big but the offshoots
of Standard Oil
um so Standard Oil was eventually broken
up and so in the 1930s uh Teddy
Roosevelt made monopolies illegal and
they did it because of Standard Oil the
offshoots of Standard Oil which they
broke up it's like be I believe it's BP
it's Exxon it's Conoco it's mobile all
those companies came from Standard Oil
it was as if Amazon Facebook and Google
or one company basically accounted for a
huge percentage of the economy
and John Rockefeller though you think of
this guy or you think of a business
person nowadays as being this like
really vicious person and he was kind of
vicious but he was very interesting in
that he broke a lot of stereotypes in my
head a few interesting lines from that
book
one he said I would rather earn one
percent off a hundred people's efforts
than a hundred percent of my own efforts
and so right now on Twitter and in my
world we're seeing lots of things about
solo businesses and so a lot of people
take pride in Solo businesses and I
think many times they're great but I
have one big issue with them which is if
you're a solo business that means you're
the only one doing all the work and John
Rockefeller in that line where he talks
about one percent of other people versus
100 of his that kind of changed my
thinking where it's significantly better
even if someone isn't as good as you
it's better to have a handful of those
people doing a lot of the work versus
only you doing the work
that like kind of changed my thinking on
on on
what it means to be a sole business
because I'm like I would way rather have
um
a bunch of people doing a little bit of
work and then he has this other line
that says the ability to deal with
people is a per is as perchable
purchasable a commodity as sugar and
coffee
and I pay more for that ability than any
other Under the Sun and I thought that
was interesting because I'm not the best
manager but I can hire good managers and
so that kind of like got rid of the the
blocker ahead of my head of like well if
he says that hiring people is good but
I'm not good at managing them oh cool I
can hire people to manage them so that
was like really useful for me he also
has this uh great learning about gaining
a skill so I'm a huge fan of telling
people look before you start a company
or before you go and uh and try to do
your own thing you need to learn a skill
in my case it was copywriting I'm a big
fan of copywriting but he's got this
great line
where he talks about his time as an
accountant so from the ages of 16 to
like 19 or 20 he was an accountant for a
small firm that's where he learned about
operations and where he learned about
like where does money come from how
should it be accounted for how to uh
great operations look like he's got this
great line where he goes oh how blessed
the young men are who have struggled for
a foundation in the beginning of Life
I'll never cease to be grateful for the
three and a half years I spent as an
apprentice and so that's where he learns
all about uh the the the the the the
ability to overcome to adapt to get a
skill and so that kind of changed my
life there's this other great book
called Mastery by Robert Greene and the
whole book is about on how you should
develop a skill because in learning that
skill it teaches you and uh how to
master something and it also opens doors
for you and you could use that skill in
other unrelated fields and that's how
you become incredibly successful I'm a
big fan of learning a skill and John
Rockefeller is one of the guys who
taught me the importance of that I used
to think being a generalist was good not
anymore I don't think that anymore and
it's because of this book Titan and the
last thing I said previously that he um
was a really nice guy uh he was vicious
in business I mean he would basically go
out and buy all these small oil
refineries and uh if they didn't sell he
goes hey look I'm going to write you a
fair deal
if you don't take my offer I'm gonna
trust you I'll show you all my
accounting and all my Revenue so you
know I'm gonna Crush you so I think you
should take this deal so we can get rich
to get rich get we can get rich together
otherwise you're dead
a lot of them took him up on that and
they did get rich some of them they
didn't and so he was pretty vicious but
he was pretty much nice along the way
there's this famous story about how uh
once his company got big Rockefeller had
this piece of exercise equipment and he
was like rolling the exercise equipment
into the office and this accountant who
hadn't recognized Rockefeller said hey
you got to get that out of here you
can't have that here and so Rockefeller
just looked at him and goes oh all right
I'm sorry and he politely took the
exercise equipment uh out of that room
and moved it to another room he didn't
like snap back like do you know who I am
and I thought that that was really
interesting and like a cool way of
handling it and show that you can be a
polite guy you could be kind and vicious
in business they're not opposites
another thing is that he was famous for
like laying down during meetings and
closing his eyes because he just said
this is just easier for me to listen and
uh they used to like uh talk about him
behind his back and they would say man
this guy Rockefeller it feels like he's
sleeping like he doesn't even pay
attention to what we're saying in the
meetings and he would say no I'm I'm
listening uh like I I choose to let
everyone talk I want to sit back and say
nothing and I'm just going to sit in
silence and at the end of the meeting
I'll say thank you everyone but he just
would sit and listen he would barely
talk and someone asked him why and he
recited this poem that he would say
constantly he said a wise uh a wise old
owl lived in an oak the more he saw the
less he spoke the less he spoke the more
he heard why aren't we all like that old
bird and so he would like just sit and
listen and then when he had to make a
decision he had all types of information
that he needed in order to make that uh
decision and so I used to think that
when you're up this big successful
businessman you got to be the one doing
all the talking
no it's the opposite you got to be doing
all the listening and finally he did a
very good job of complimenting people so
whenever he saw someone
who was making a mistake he was famous
for complimenting them first so like for
example there was this accountant uh
that who he had and Rockefeller was an
old uh former accountant he saw a
mistake and he goes these books are very
well kept very well indeed however I
noticed one little small mistake right
here and it was like actually a pretty
big Heir but he was really good at
catching the mistake complimenting him
first and then uh uh getting them to
correct it because they knew that the
way that you motivate people is you kind
of got to make them respect you a little
bit you can't uh
insult them in front of a bunch of
people and he did a really good job of
uh of handling people and I thought that
that was a really fascinating uh thing
for him to do as opposed to being like
this guy in TV Show Who's like you made
this video you're fired in front of
everyone to make an ordeal out of it uh
so I thought that was interesting so
these are the three books Titan the
operator and undaunted courage go and
check him out I'm a big fan of them
[Music]